RELEASED MORE DECLASSIFIED
MATERIALS RELATING TO THE ABUSE
INVESTIGATION.
JOINING US NOW TO BREAK DOWN ALL
OF THIS, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THERE’S A LOT TO DECIPHER HERE.
CAN I ASK A QUESTION ON THIS
FIRST MEMO?
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHY THIS, I
ASSUME THIS CAME FROM THE FBI?
I ASSUME DIRECTOR WRAY SAW THIS.
THIS LETTER TO FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE COURT.
THIS IS JULY OF 2018 LINDSAY.
THEY ARE JUSTIFYING THE USE OF
THIS DOSSIER WHEN IT WAS A YEAR
AND A HALF EARLIER THAT THEY
DEBUNKED IT?
>> YOU NAILED IT.
THERE’S TWO THINGS IMPORTANT
TONIGHT.
THE LEGAL FOUNDATION FOR
MUELLER’S APPOINTMENT IS
CRUMBLING.
THE MEMO TO MUELLER WAS GIVEN TO
ME FULLY UNREDACTED.
SO NOW WE KNOW THAT THE SCOPE OF
THE INVESTIGATION WAS TO LOOK AT
CARTER PAGE, FLYNN, AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE WORKING
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
NOW THIS IS IN AUGUST OF 2017.
YOU NAILED IT.
IN JULY OF -- EXCUSE ME JANUARY
OF 2017.
THE SUB SOURCE DISAVOWED THE
DOSSIER.
AND WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THERE
IS NO WARRANT.
SO THEY KNEW THAT THE CARTER
PAGE THING WAS A FRAUD.
THEY WANTED TO CLOSE THE CASE
AGAINST FLYNN.
WE HAVE HIM ON RECORD DENYING
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
A SAINT TO DO SO WOULD BE
TREASON.
SO THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS
CRUMBLING.
NOW AND --
>> Sean: SLOW DOWN A SECOND
PIT I WANT TO STAY ON THE
TIMELINE HERE.
THIS MEMO, THIS IS AUGUST OF
2017.
ROD ROSENSTEIN.
NOW WE ARE UP TO THE FOURTH
APPLICATION.
NOW LET’S STAY ON THE DATES FOR
ONE SECOND.
THE ONLY SOURCE FOR THIS HAD TO
BE STEEL.
BY AUGUST OF 2017, FOR THE SCOPE
MEMO, AND THE FINAL RENEWAL OR
THIRD RENEWAL FOURTH WARRANT.
BY THAT TIME, THEY KNEW BACK IN
FEBRUARY OF 2017 THAT IT WAS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
AND THE SOURCE WAS STEEL.
THEY KNEW IT WAS B.S. MONTHS
EARLIER.
SO NOW THE QUESTION, SENATOR, IS
WHAT THE HELL WENT ON HERE?
>> WELL, THE LEGAL FOUNDATION IN
MY VIEW DOES NOT EXIST.
THAT’S WHAT THIS MEMO IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THEY NAME FOR PEOPLE.
ROSENSTEIN TELLS MUELLER TO LOOK
ATAT FOUR PEOPLE.
CARTER PAGE BEFORE.
YOU JUST SAID IT BETTER THAN
ANYBODY.
IN JANUARY, EIGHT MONTHS BEFORE
THE SUB SOURCE DISAVOWED THE
DOSSIER, THERE WAS NO LEGAL
JUSTIFICATION TO SUSPECT CARTER
PAGE OF BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT
BECAUSE IT ALL DEPENDED ON THE
DOSSIER.
AND THAT CRUMBLED IN JANUARY.
FLYNN’S CASE WAS LOOKED OUT BY
THE FIELD OFFICE IN WASHINGTON,
JANUARY THE 4TH OF 2017.
THEY SAID THERE’S NO REASON TO
BELIEVE HE IS DOING ANYTHING
WRONG.
HE SHOULDN’T BE PART OF A
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
PAPADOPOULOS IN 2016 DENYING
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS,
SAYING TO DO SO WOULD BE
TREASON.
SO THERE IS NO LEGITIMATE REASON
TO BELIEVE ANY OF THESE FOUR
WERE WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS
ON AUGUST 2ND 2017.
THEREFORE, THE ENTIRE PIECE OF
WAS A LEGITIMATE TO BEGIN WITH.
THAT’S VERY IMPORTANT.
>> IT’S NOT ONLY A LEGITIMATE, W
ARE TALKING ABOUT A SHREDDING OF
EVERY BIT OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW THAT WE WOULD EVER HAVE,
AND THEY ARE DOING IT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING, NEVER VERIFIABLE
TO STOP SOMEBODY FROM WINNING
ELECTION.
AND WHEN THEY WIN THE ELECTION,
THEY ARE TRYING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO USE FALSE INFORMATION TO
BASICALLY TAKE THIS GUY DOWN.
AND THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE
DOING, THEY HAD ALL THE EVIDENCE
THAT THEY WERE DOING IT, AND
THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
CELESTIA SLOW DOWN FOR A SECOND.
I WISH A DEMOCRAT WOULD TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: DON’T HOLD YOUR
BREATH, YOU WILL DROP DEAD.
>> NOW I KNOW.
NOW I KNOW WHY MUELLER DIDN’T
FIND ANYTHING.
>> Sean: THEY KNEW, THIS
PROVES THEY KNEW!
THEY KNEW.
BEFORE IT EVEN STARTED, THEY
KNEW.
>> OKAY, NUMBER TWO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WRITING TO THE COURT IN 2018.
THIS IS 2018.
IN 2018, JANUARY OF 2018, DEVIN
NUNES WRITES A MEMO CRITICAL OF
THE APPLICATION.
THE MEMO IS VERY CRITICAL OF THE
CARTER PAGE APPLICATION.
HERE’S WHAT THE COURT IS TOLD BY
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN JULY OF 2018.
THEY SAY IN THE LETTER TO THE
COURT KNOW, THE APPLICATION IS
GOOD.
IT’S SOLID, IT SOUNDS.
A FEW TECHNICAL IRREGULARITIES.
THEY REPEAT THE LIE THAT THE SUB
SOURCE WAS TRUTHFUL AND
COOPERATIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS, TELLING THE
COURT THAT THE SUB SOURCE
VALIDATED THE DOSSIER RATHER
THAN SHREDDED IT.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY REPEATING THAT
LIE AGAIN IN 2018.
ONLY UNTIL HOROWITZ CAME ALONG.
WHY COULDN’T THEY HAVE FOUND
WHAT HOROWITZ FOUND.
THEY HAVE A MEMO FOR EVERYBODY
TO SEE INDICATING THAT THE SUB
SOURCE, THE RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE,
SAID THE DOSSIER WAS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE.
IT WAS HEARSAY, BARTOK.
>> Sean: SENATOR, ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE WROTE THE LAW, DIDN’T
THEY?
>> I’M TELLING YOU, THIS IS
J. EDGAR HOOVER STUFF.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
WHERE’S DIRECTOR WRAY?
I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE YELLING
AT ME TONIGHT HE’S NOT DOING HIS
JOB.
>> IN JULY 2018, HOW COULD YOU
POSSIBLY TELL THE COURT THAT THE
SUB SOURCE WAS TRUTHFUL AND
COOPERATIVE WHEN THE MEMO IN THE
FILE SAYS HE UNDERCUT THE
DOSSIER?
THEY ARE REPEATING THE LIE TO
THE COURT THAT HOROWITZ FOUND.
THAT’S TELLING ME THE FBI’S NOT
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
AND AS LATE AS JULY OF 2018.
BEYOND ANY DOUBT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, THIS IS AN
ATTEMPTED COUP.